bakou
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
suite à météo sur la première la météo
avec vers l'est au spécialiste de
l'assainissement individuel et de la
récupération d'eau de pluie
www.valeo.com nuage d un versement se
partager le ciel et surtout sur l'est du
département des images qui vont se
développer et vont devenir de plus en
plus menaçant avec une tendance orageuse
qui va se dessiner principalement sur le
sud et l'ouest de notre département de
la pluie sur les hauts de saint leu 28
degrés pour le tampon également 24
degrés pour la plaine des cafres et 32
points saint-andré la météo avec vers
l'est au spécialiste de l'assainissement
individuel et de la récupération d'eau
de pluie www.valeo.com 12h17 merci
d'écouter la première c'est le lundi
politique et gaëlle dantec reçoit
gilbert annette le maire de saint denis
lundi politique gagne le dantec
bonjour j'ai dit bonjour à tous la crise
des gilet jaune at elle influencé la
politique dans le chef-lieu comment
répondre aux intrants sur le pouvoir
d'achat l'emploi ou la participation
citoyenne quand on est le maire de la
plus grande ville de la réunion et qu'on
soutient la politique d magal macro
comment préparer les prochaines
élections qu'on sera prêts qu'ils se
divisent entre socialistes et marcheurs
gilles merlette maire de saint denis
conseiller régional d'opposition il
habitait dans des politiques jusqu'à 13
heures sur la première vos questions à
partir de 12h45 au 02 62 90 à 2000
j'ai un bon jour oui bonjour merci
d'être avec nous ce midi dans
l'actualité il ya d'abord ce centre de
loisirs des jeunes dissous jeudi dernier
en parler dans le journal depuis ce
centre favoriser une proximité du
quartier et la police y ait autant pour
les policiers pour prévenir la
délinquance
le patron de la police nationale à la
réunion françois legault qui préside
cette structure promet une roue
réouverture mais jean-luc ryanair était
l'invité ce matin de deux filles dernier
sur la première unis croient pas trop il
sait qu'il a créé un ce centre est ici
adresser à vous gilbert annette
ils demandent ce que vous preniez vos
responsabilités dans ce dossier dans va
de l'avenir des relations du quartier
pour cela dit-il qu'est-ce que vous avez
tous les cas ce que je sais c'est que la
direction de la police air à 10 ou se
sentent pour malversations donc à
l'origine il ya probablement des
malversations
moi je n'ai pas eu à me prononcer sur
ces malversations tous les cas ce que je
veux dire c'est que nous avons un
excellent partenariat avec la police et
bien sûr le directeur monsieur lebon
puisque vous le savez nous avons obtenu
-16%
enfin ils sont à venir monsieur sur
cette affaire particulièrement sur son
centre va je vais l'étudier mais je n'ai
pas la capacité à desiles très vite
rendus sentent aujourd'hui on va étudier
je pense qu'on aura une action pour la
version d'utilité pourquoi non mais sont
utiles et il y avait la police de
proximité
sarkozy a rayé la police de proximité
aujourd'hui le gouvernement semble
vouloir mettre une certaine police de la
quotidienneté sur le départ d'ozil hier
nous travaillons sur cela avec un
objectif réduire la délinquance et nous
avons eu un excellent chiffre -16%
nous sommes la première ville française
de plus de cent cinquante mille
habitants avoir le plus faible taux de
délinquance mieux que dijon mieux
grenoble pourquoi est-ce que vous lui
attribuez recensé que les la situation
sociale difficile pour les jeunes
c'est un beau combat perspective eux en
terme d'emplois d'insertion sociale de
l'ascension sociale dès lors forcément
de la frustration et de et de la
délinquance possible qu'est ce qui fait
que vous avez les bons chiffres sont
donnés
moi je pense qu'il ya d'abord la
solidarité familiale c'est que dans les
familles réunionnaises
un jeune qui a 22 25 ans qui est en
difficulté on le met pas la porte il est
il est accueilli les maintenue jusqu'à
ce qu'ils puissent je dirais subvenir à
ses besoins dont il ya ça il ya toutes
les actions de la vie associative et
puis il ya je dirais la l'amélioration
de du travail de la police qui a
aujourd'hui un observatoire précis qui
déplace ses troupes qui arrive à
contredire à contrebalancer la
délinquance
nous avons eu par exemple moins 30% de
délinquance la nuit donc c'est la
qualité du travail de la police que je
veux remercier
et puis il ya ce dossier particulier sur
le sens de jeunesse fait des loisirs du
chaudron on va le faire mais je vais le
faire bien sûr en relation avec la
direction de la police qui est bien sûr
un partenaire privilégié dans c'est un
mouvement d'aidé la région de revoir son
budget 2010 9 pour y intégrer les
réponses aux revendications de pouvoir
achat vous êtes vous conseiller une
autre position vous êtes penser la
semaine dernière sur ses intentions
musicales vous vous y opposer notamment
à l'idée d'une continuité territoriale
des biens et des marchandises des fastes
pour faire baisser le prix de
si on fait un petit calcul enlevé au
budget de la région qui doit intervenir
sur la formation l'école l'illettrisme
et m 80 millions de budget sur le fret
passe 40 millions pour l'instant non
mais j'ai entendu le président qui
voulait même aller à 86 et 40 millions
écoutez moi ça fait 1 euro par personne
et par an dont détruire 40 millions de
budget ailleurs un sur l'illettrisme par
exemple où on bat des records ou sur la
formation pour mais donner 1 euro par
personne par semaine
je pense que c'est ridicule c'est pas la
bonne mesure mais surtout ce qui est
grave c'est que on met un coup de
poignard dans la production
ces sacs il a dit dans ça sera ça serait
que pour des produits qui ne sont pas
faciles à écouter qui peut prévoir ce
qui sera produit à lyon dans dix vingt
ans tous les cas les producteurs locaux
tous on dit attention attention en ce
pourquoi parce que nos achats
d'aujourd'hui sont les emplois de demain
acheter localement c'est important et
surtout pour les investisseurs si vous
voulez investir et que vous dites que
vous êtes à la merci d'une décision de
la région qui peut demain subventionné
l'importation de produits concurrents
vous n'investissez pas la réunion vous
avez peur parce que pour un investisseur
pour ceux qui produisent localement il
faut une garantie de retour sur
investissement sur 20 ans dans cette
mesure est très mauvaise d'ailleurs le
président de la république c'est c'est
exceptionnel publiquement a dit son
opposition à cette mesure dans un débat
public que tout le monde arbres il a dit
vous ne pouvez pas dire aujourd'hui je
subventionne le fred de la plaquette de
beurre parce que ça voudrait dire que à
jamais la réunion produira du beurre
dont le président s'est permis de
contredire de dire que c'est pas une une
idée c'est pas une bonne idée c'est une
mauvaise idée que de prendre l'argent
public des impôts pour subventionner le
ferait qu il ya d'autres mesures à faire
pour le thé le président le président de
la république ce jour-là a aussi dit si
mes souvenirs sont bons que qui sont
d'aider à l'importation de produits tant
qu'il n'y avait pas plus de transparence
sur les marges des opérateurs disant
attention les élus locaux vous êtes des
fois très proche des personnalités
économiques et pressez vous qui n'allait
pas aller dans le bon sens parce que ça
vous arrange
oui il a sous-entendu que le monde
économique et subventionner leurs idées
et des certains politiques en tous les
cas c'est pas le cas
et moi je ne raisonne pas partir de là
vous savez moi dans ma vie
professionnelle j'étais le directeur de
l'oréal et je connais les marges les
entreprises et je pense qu'effectivement
il y a des positions dominantes qu'il
faut aller voir de plus près et l'état
doit agir sur certaines marches il ya un
travail à faire sur je dirais les marges
les profits de certains groupes
et ça c'est pas fait ça fait des années
qu'on concentre je sais pourquoi
pourquoi c'est moi parce que on est dans
le système commercial libéral c'est à
dire que
la concurrence qui doit réguler les prix
or la concurrence ne s'exerce pas
pleinement parce que précisément nous
sommes à dix mille kilomètres nous
sommes un petit et des toits et tout le
monde n'est pas en compétition à la
réunion dont il n'y a pas un vrai
système de concurrence donc il ya ici et
la démarche importante et des gens qui
gagnent beaucoup d'argent donc il faut
que l'état mette son nez qui soit plus
dirigiste sur cette partie là que ce ne
soit pas dans le libéralisme total qu'on
n'aide un certain nombre de produits à
être régulés pour le pouvoir d'achat que
des réunionnais notamment des
réunionnais en difficulté pour revenir à
7 cette question de la proximité entre
le monde politique et le monde
économique est ce que le financement des
partis le financement des élections par
des entreprises gagnent implanté ici
est-ce que c'est du passé
écoutez il ya des règles aujourd'hui ce
qui n'était pas le cas il ya trente ans
il ya des règles
aujourd'hui les entreprises on peut
faire des deux camps 75000 euros il faut
les déclarer les budgets de campagne sis
a changé sont plafonnés moi je peux
raconter la campagne 89 milieu où il n'y
avait pas de plafonnement donc mon
adversaire avait dix fois plus de créer
aujourd'hui c'est plus possible il ya un
plafonnement et surtout ceux qui
participent au financement à titre
individuel pâtit d'entreprises sont les
personnes physiques peuvent déduire
souvent 50 60 % de leurs dons donc
aujourd'hui une forme de transparence
il n'y a pas besoin d'être du monde
économique dans la politique
évidemment les les chefs d'entreprise
peuvent à titre personnel participer
jusqu'à soixante quinze mille euros à
des campagnes mais c'est limiter à ça
les campagnes sont limitées non ça c'est
un procès du passé c'est n'existe sur le
pou le pouvoir d'achat un autre levier
que soit réutilisé c'est l'autre mère on
sait bien que c'est parce que les
recettes de la traverse est aussi une
partie du budget des communes
comment est-ce que vous en tant que
maire et en tant que conseiller
oui c'est parce qu'on part pas de la
base on ne parle pas de ce qui a été à
l'origine de l'autre mercier quoi c'est
que la capacité contributive du
réunionnais qui je le rappelle est trois
fois plus pauvres quand vous prenez le
voulait le nombre de pauvres à la
réunion nous sommes à 42% canton
métropole on est à 14 dont la réunion à
le concitoyen revenait à une faiblesse
contributives
or les collectivités locales les maires
dont je suis eh bien ils ont les mêmes
compétences le même obligation donc les
tailles des années a considéré que pour
palier à cette faiblesse contributive du
citoyen il ménagé une recette qui est
l'octroi de mer mais et en contrepartie
ils baissaient la tva un taux réduit la
tva la réunion mais l'état l'avait
requis et quand même payé par mais sinon
ça serait la tva comme en france si on
veut un système équivalent égalé bien
remettrai la tva à 20% et tout le monde
perd et la tva donc aujourd'hui l'octroi
de mer c'est il permet la région perçoit
110 millions de l'octroi de mer les
communes 350 millions répartis pour
compenser pour saint denis ça fait que
ça fait combien à une quarantaine de
millions mais si on supprimait ça il
faudrait le remplacer probablement par
une dotation de l'état qui augmenterait
la tva dont la réunion serait perdante
parce qu'à côté de ça l'octroi de mer
protège quelques productions locales
et ça c'est important et l'octroi de mer
est décidé par les instances locales qui
peuvent moduler en fonction des tel ou
tel produit que ça donc c'est un outil à
la portée des ré des réunionnais à
travers leurs instances et la région
notamment dont il ne faut pas faire
croire aux réunionnais qu'on supprimera
l'autre de nerfs sans le remplacer par
une note dotation d'autres marques ont
conduit aux verts espèrent dégager entre
50 et en révisant le travers
il trompe le jour où écouter de toute
façon il va réduire si vous réduisez les
les recettes des collectivités déjà
l'état l'a fait ça se traduit par quoi -
25% d'investissements et quand vous
investissez - vous avez moins de marchés
moins de travaux moins d'emplois donc on
peut réduire et les subventions
collectivités et demain il n'y aura plus
de chanter public pas d'emplois plus de
chômage donc est ce qu'il faut et c'est
le vrai débat pour vous ou pour un non
est ce qu'il faut non mais c'est un
débat que les réunionnais doivent venait
est-ce qu'il faut privilégier
écoutez moi bien le pouvoir d'achat ou
l'emploi est aujourd'hui le différentiel
le pouvoir d'achat et lexis entre les
réunionnais et la métropole
mais le plus grand différentiel c'est
l'emploi nous sommes nous à 24 % de
chômage en france métropolitaine et à 9
donc nous soit on dit que le vent entre
les deux il faut choisir et nous nous
disons c'est l'emploi parce que quand on
ne travaille pas et bien bien sûr c'est
de pouvoir d'achat en moins mais c'est
surtout la misère morale c'est la misère
humaine extraordinaire 24 % de chômage
c'est le problème numéro un le problème
numéro 2 c'est le pouvoir d'achat
l'accent sur l'emploi la région propose
de tripler les pecs vous nos deux des
emplois et des 3000 ans est un marchand
souviens j'avais beaucoup défendu les
emplois aidés quand d'un coup ils ont
été menacés et notamment dans cette
marche on dit que c'est une bonne option
vous avez en fait est aujourd'hui le
centre dans le secteur marchand ils
doivent payer sont 10% l'état considère
qu'il va aider pour qu'il reste 50 % est
ce que les employeurs du secteur
marchand justement si une situation de
crise va avoir recours au pecq
c'est la réponse il faut attendre pour
le dire ce qui est ou bien marché des
propositions le second je sais combien
quelques centaines d'émissions avant le
31 décembre par la mi-cinquantaine
évolue au rythme
non mais finalement sauf que sauf que la
vérité la vérité ce qu'il faut dire aux
réunionnais c'est que quand en france
métropolitaine
le chômage a baissé de -2 28% il a
augmenté à la réunion de pub à peu près
le même si sur lui or nous nous sommes
sinistrés nous ment beaucoup plus de
choses c'est de dire que quelque part la
mini c'est tromper l on a appliqué
brutalement des mesures notamment de
suppression des contrats aidés et qui
ont provoqué cette augmentation du
chômage donc aujourd'hui il faut bien
sûr revenir là dessus
sauf que dans la présentation de la
région et je conteste c'est ce que j'ai
lu on annonce 10 mille emplois et on dit
3000 pec
donc il ya mensonge quelque part en tous
les cas il ya une manipulation il y aura
pas dix mille emplois nouveaux
on veut aider à plus de pecs bien sûr un
mois je suis je suis pour puisque vient
chômage les gens veulent des paies sauf
qu'il ya une partie des pecs les 1500
mis au niveau des entreprises
moi je suis pas certain mais j'attends
de voir que les entreprises vont saisir
à 50%
moi je trouve que c'est cher pour les
entreprises parce que impec
c'est quelqu'un qui est très éloignées
de l'emploi donc et peu productif donc
est ce que un chef d'entreprise qui a
besoin
je sais pas moi d'un chauffeur routier
aux gars va prendre un pic qui n'est pas
qualifié ça c'est une autre question
donc on verra à l'épreuve mais on est
loin des 10000 emplois parce que
aujourd'hui les emplois qui seraient
rendus par l'aide aux pme est écouté
aujourd'hui
moi j'ai reconnu le président d art et
chief du tourisme à janvier points 23 %
nous avons à résorber
l'impact de la crise des gilet jaune sur
un certain nombre de secteurs d'activité
et notamment du tourisme donc
aujourd'hui il faut consolider les
entreprises pour rattraper les chiffres
d'affaires perdus et les conséquences
sur l'emploi en 2010 mme est-ce que des
pecs à la mairie de saint denis il va y
avoir plus
j'espère moi j'avais grosso modo pas la
mairie mais la mairie plus les
associations d'insertion 1500 contrats
aujourd'hui nous n'aurons plus que 500
donc nous espérons avoir des moyens
supplémentaires pour répondre à la
demande de tous ceux qui ce qui vaut au
pôle emploi pour avoir un contrat aidé
globalement
cet épisode 2d gigean termes de pouvoir
d'achat d'emploi vous avez vous à la
mairie
changer un peu votre fusil les prions
d'orientation man à corriger notamment
je voulais dit enfin je les dis nous
avons augmenté notre budget social
d'intervention sociale qui était de cinq
cent mille euros
nous devons passer à un million donc
doublé c'est important en particulier en
prenant des mesures de restriction sur
ce qu'on appelle le standing
vous savez quatre ans c'est à dire qu'on
a supprimé notamment tout tout tout ces
cocktails etc
donc nous avons réduit de deux cent
mille euros de se laisser enfermer
nous avons réduit un certain nombre de
dépenses folles avaient pour deux cent
mille euros cocktail oui oui dans la
bible c'est une grande ville etc
mais on faisait comme faisait
précédemment les gens on a considéré
qu'il fallait revenir là dessus donc on
est revenus courageusement mais vous
savez que la mairie de saint-denis moi
j'ai supprimé les voitures de fonction
j'ai gagné 24% sur le carburant
aujourd'hui aucun élu même le maire n'a
plus de voiture de fonction aucun élu
aucun administratif j'avais 100 cadres
qui avaient une voiture de fonction d'un
supprimés aujourd'hui les élus et les
cas de voyage en classe économique dont
vous nous aviez déjà annoncé samedi que
ce qu'il ya du nouveau est ce que c'est
bien d'aider des restrictions le dire
sur les heures supplémentaires
on a on a raboté 500000 euros pour ce
budget là on a augmenté et là je
m'apprête à rediscuter ce qu'on appelle
le budget supplémentaire donc nous avons
des bonnes nouvelles sur le compte
administratif 2018
nous avons fait un peu mieux que nous
espérions donc nous allons remettre
notamment en insertion parce que le gros
problème c'est l'emploi
nous avons une dizaine de chantiers
d'insertion j'espère doubler ce nombre
de chantiers avec une partie de ce que
nous avons obtenu comme je dirais marge
de ban avec le compte administratif et
le bois le budget supplémentaire donc
nous prenons des mesures pour améliorer
nous prenons aussi mais nous l'avions
déjà fait nous avions des conseils de
quartier extra nous intensifions à moi
même dès mercredi prochain je vais faire
un facebook live chez l'habitant
donc tous les mercredis on va reparler
dans les deux sets sur le budget celui
de la région parce que
voilà c'est les productions que fait
dire au moins dans le budget est
récompensé on parle de revenir sur la
continuité territoriale sur le prends
pas pousser ces deux pistes
écoutez nous allons voir puisque pour
l'instant eu des orientations elles sont
un peu verbale ce qu'il faudra c'est
voir dans les chiffres a donc quelques
semaines dans quelques semaines avec le
budget passera en revue puis on verra
qu'est ce qu'ils ont fait mais nous nous
considérons que les gilets jaunes n'ont
pas émis de 2 enfin je ne riez pas des
problèmes nouveaux -sauf c'est une
expression de ses aigus ce qu'il faut
toucher par exemple à la continuité
je pense qu'elle mérite d'être
réexaminés pourquoi parce que le prix
des billets d'avion a diminué donc c'est
normal que la région ne met pas 500
euros sur un billet qui et qui demain va
coûter 500 euros à 300 euros donc il
faut réajuster les choses je pense qu'il
faut le faire gilbert annette le maire
de saint denis est l'invité de lundi
politique vous pouvez lui poser vos
questions dans une dizaine de minutes
86e rejet des élus massif ou épuisés en
général assez peu distinction rejet les
élus rejet des institutions suisses et
démocratique tel qu'il fonctionne parce
que d'abord vous l'avez vécu sous les
cultures injuste sur votre sens je pense
que dans la population je dirais
française réunionnaise il y à une remise
en cause de la démocratie représentative
puisque nos citoyens considèrent que le
politique n'arrive pas à faire face à la
crise de la société d'un qu'elles ont
des dons ils sont pointés comme un peu
responsable de la persistance de cette
les ondes ou global ensuite quel
problème du comportement des élus moi je
prêche et je suis mes cellules les élus
doivent corriger leur comportement
les élus doivent être exemplaires
exemplaires dans l'utilisation de
l'argent public et à un argent payé par
les contribuables c'est pour ça moi j'ai
interdit les classements les billets
d'avion le luxe en quelque chose nous
devons être sobre c'est pas le cas de
certaines collectivités
il ya trop de voitures de fonction trop
de dépenses tapageuse il faut corriger
la population souffre elle voit des élus
se complaire à dépenser de l'argent donc
il faut être exemplaire il faut être
juste aussi ce que j'ai perçu dans dans
dans le cri déchire et jaune que j'avais
quand même remarqué ces îles il ya un
rejet de l'injustice
vous comprenez et notre société et lass
est injuste et je dois dire
qu'aujourd'hui le ne constitue l
impression que la politique menée par le
gouvernement est aussi injuste donc elle
remet en cause le fait que par exemple
les premières mesures du gouvernement à
exonérer ceux qui étaient les mieux
placés dans la société je pense l'impôt
sur leurs factures et qu'elle a pénalisé
des gens modestes à 1200 euros
notamment avec l'augmentation de la csg
on va reparler de politique politicienne
intéressant mais vous en voulez vous
d'avoir soutenu
emmanuel macron qui a mis en place
écoutez aujourd'hui je je je pose la
question qui aurait soutenu
1 est ce que j'aurai soutenu votre
mélenchon non mélenchon oui mais mon
parti le candidat ment partie amont avec
sa proposition j'étais content donc
j'allais pas le soutenir
et c'est son résultat m'a donné raison
avec 6% moi je suis pour l'efficacité le
contraire tout le monde ne soit pas
enterrée
oui mais pourquoi le manque de soutien
alors que le ps était autour de 20% s'il
a fait 6 c'est que bien sûr il a
découragé beaucoup de socialistes qui a
vous savez que 55% des sympathisants
socialistes ont soutenu macro même si
aujourd'hui
bien évidemment il ya un regard critique
de ceux qui commencent eux tenus macron
n'ont pas encore critique ou des regrets
non pas des regrets parce qu' à la plage
aurait pas bonne fillon je pas voter
fillon fillon voulait la suppression de
tous les emplois aidés voulait supprimer
500 mille fonctionnaires à maquereau il
en fait 120 milles et et c'est pas bon
dont je qui oserait marine le pen donc
c'est le choix parce qu'il n'y avait pas
de choix on a fait le choix de la
responsabilité
moi je ne je ne reviens pas sur ce choix
mais je suis critique aujourd'hui avec
le la gestion avec le discours avec le
comportement sauf qu'il n'y avait pas
d'autre choix je vais pas parler de
regret je n'aurais pas voter mélenchon
c'est sûr parce que c'est très
démagogique
avec on le smig à 1800 euros et c'est
assez catastrophique amont et est
apparue au dernier moment avec son
revenu universel il voulait donner même
de l'argent à madame de
temps court donc c'était presque
loufoque donc moi voilà j'ai fait un
choix responsable que j'assume même si
je suis déçu d'une partie de la fonction
mais le débat continue nous verrons si
macro redresse et je pense que les 10
milliards 10 q et c'est un bon signe
avoir remonté par exemple plafond des
retraités à 2000 euros
le demi de 1200 en même temps ça ne pas
calmer l'auvent j'ai joué whissell a
réduit sensiblement et vous voyez bien
les projections notamment dans les
intentions de vote aux européennes la
liste des filets jaunes les gilet jaune
même qui conteste les élus mais quand
eux doivent choisir un représentant
vous voyez la cacophonie comment il
s'agit pas s'il suffit pas de pousser
des cris
il faut s'organiser pour ensuite peser
dans le débat pour prendre des
responsabilités
et là on voit bien que ce mouvement qui
eut le mérite d'exister le mérite de
faire remonter des revendications mais
aujourd'hui pour gérer pour introduire
ses revendications dans la gestion du
pays dans les budgets
eh bien ils sont en grande difficulté
justement les tentatives d'organisation
composé par exemple la journ conseil
consultatif citoyen avec peut-être un
peu plus de démocratie locale dans les
institutions existantes vous y prendre
part bien sûr la mairie a mis en place
huit devant les cahiers de doléances ou
les avons regroupés envoyé à la
préfecture
nous avons terminé neuf débat public
dans le cadre du grand débat nous allons
nous ont pris à vous en retenez quoi se
sent écouté mais que c'était moyen
le petit a semblé je vais dire 30
personnes en moyenne 40 qui avait envie
de s'exprimer donc se sont exprimés on
va relever un nous devons rémunérer un
organisme pour traiter cela faire la
synthèse et nous allons bien sûr faire
parvenir au président appelé comme il le
souhaitait la synthèse ses demandes
mais la difficulté c'est bien d'entendre
il fallait entendre mieux entendre et je
pense que il y avait un vrai besoin
d'être écoutés mais aujourd'hui le
rendez vous c'est la confection de la
réponse quelle réponse on va faire
qu'est-ce qu'on va apporter de nouveau
de plus à ses revendications de justice
sociale à ces revendications de plus je
dirais de corriger cette démocratie
participative qui donne des signes de
fatigue comment vous avez des idées vous
bien sûr mais je ses idées sont en train
d'être débattue en je pense qu'il faut
augmenter la part de la démocratie
participative trouvé laissant les
conseils de quartier de choses dont
sexistes sein de fond les mineurs c'est
pas suffire marche pas pourquoi ça
marche pas eh bien je pense que les gens
veulent davantage aux prérogatives
davantage alors vous savez que le débat
fondamental c'est est ce que on peut
confier le pouvoir de décider à des
personnes qui n'ont pas été élus
ça c'est une vraie un vrai donc moi je
pense qu'il faut réfléchir
je suis très curieux puisque vous le
savez y est exigée j'invite ceux qui
connaissent pas à regarder le film
demain où il ya et je me suis intéressé
à ça puisque j'étais en vacances dans le
tamil nadu
il ya une ville dans le tamil nadu où
l'ensemble des élus auraient été tirés
au sort et ça a bien marché
ça a donné de bons résultats alors bon
c'est un exemple il faudra voir s'il
peut être dupliqué en tout cas le tirage
au sort des citoyens volontaires
ça peut au moins complété par ce que nos
concitoyens ont l'impression qu'ils sont
mal représenté que ceux qui les
représentent
nous ne les entendent pas ou ne sont pas
suffisamment représentative donc la
démocratie participative tedder nous
nous sommes remis en cause et je
l'entends bien et je pense qu'il faut
apporter un correctif à la démocratie
représentative elle est un peu en grande
difficulté il ya vraiment une crise de
confiance dans ce système là le système
est à bout de souffle il faut le changer
ou bien la main
et donc moi je participe avec mes amis à
la recherche de solutions pour l'avenir
en attendant le conseil municipal existe
tel qu'il est prévu par les textes et
aux sources et municipales on a vu un
nouveau groupe avec du coup votre
majorité qui se divise ce que deux
conseillers municipaux
si toi aujourd'hui quitte le ps si on
reprend bien pour la république en
marche toujours pas feindre ania qui est
bien de deux positions qu'est-ce que ça
est-ce que ça sans moi je considère ça
comme une clarification ces personnes se
sont toujours affichés elle rêve elle
n'était pas elle était plus ou moins
encartés elles se sont encartés
aujourd'hui elles veulent constituer un
groupe
donc moi je trouve que c'est bien de
jouer cartes sur table de se constituer
de s'exprimer jetez-vous alors non moi
je suis au dessus des partis show
rassemble une majorité d'ailleurs ma
majorité n'étaient pas exclusivement
socialiste moi j'avais une france je
dirais de centristes avec gabriel
fontaine avec dol j'avais des écolos et
puis j'avais une la société civile le
modem avec l'oeil ex a donc moi j'ai
toujours conduit depuis 89
ma première adjointe a été barys gabriel
fontaine donc moi j'ai toujours conduit
des majorités diverses avec bien sûr une
prédominance de société sur donc
aujourd'hui nous sommes dans cette
réponse est à dire je suis un
comment vous vous êtes socialiste moi je
moi je vous dois tout parti société chez
un militant j'ai pris ma carte avec
mitterrand 61 ans dont je souhaitais
j'étais vraiment sûr vous avez toujours
aux cartes
oui je paye au parti je finance sauf que
j'étais déçu et je suis déçu du parti
ses listes aujourd'hui je trouve que par
l'incapacité de répondre aux problèmes
de suicides et de faire une offre
politique donc je donne bien sûr mon
avis à ceux qui sont responsables du
parti c est à côté de moi bien sûr il ya
il ya ericka bareigts jean philippe
naillet vu que je rencontre
quotidiennement dont je leur donne ma
position
moi pour l'instant face aux jambes
il faut voir quelle est la proposition
des socialistes vous êtes dans une sorte
de grand écart quand même entre la
république en marche est partie ses
souvenirs savoureux tout à fait non je
suis souple par nature et je fais du
yoga depuis 25 ans à améliorer ma
souplesse
donc je peux intégrer 7
ficultés qui est réelle je suis de
sensibilité j'ai adhéré j'ai milité
j'étais premier secrétaire du parti
députée sais je dois tout partie soliste
mais la réponse la posture l'offre des
socialistes aujourd'hui elle ne
satisfait pas donc j'ai fait un choix
aujourd'hui mais je suis pas lrm non
plus hein je suis je cotise au parti
stellistes je suis je me suis un peu
extirpé et je veux rassembler tous ceux
qui veulent conduire une politique de
développement assainies dans notre
projet ça ni solidaire et ceni moderne
donc je compte va falloir il va falloir
moment des prochaines échéances des
trains des étiquettes est ce que ça nous
votre succession pour l'instant mais non
il ya des étapes
moi je veux finir mon chantier je veux
réaliser 80% de mes engagements que je
suis là dessus parce que vous avez
l'intention de lancer avec je vais
observer ce que pensent mes collègues et
moi je suis dans une équipe
d'ailleurs les coups c'est quoi mon
envie c'est d'écouter ce que pensent mes
collègues pour voir quels choix nous
allons faire dans quelques mois bien sûr
à nous ferons ensemble avec ericka
bareitgs avec avec philippe maillet avec
mes messages et on déterminera calais
est la bonne stratégie qu'elle est là
mon équipe qu'elle peut occasionner vous
attention au personnel non parce que je
n'ai pas d'intention je me remets à
l'analyse de mes camarades c'est
toujours la question qu'on pose à tout
aux invités merci d'avancé pour votre la
qualité la langue de bois
non non non c'est la preuve que d'autres
choses peuvent évoluer entre autres non
je vais vous répondre seulement ce
serait imprudent de se découvrir
alors que hilda maurienne échéances
européennes il ya d'autres échéances
notamment sur des projets moi j'attends
de voir où on en est qu on va les uns
qui nous appellent de saint denis
bonjour bonjour oui bonjour s'écoute on
est très bien alors ça
mais où la raison et vous savez merci
merci merci merci
moi non mais nous nous bataillons avec
la cinor dont c'est la compétence dont
je vais dire à gérald maillot et je
profite du micro pour lui présenter mes
condoléances il a perdu sa mère qui a
été enterré hier gérald maillot mon
camarade cherhal maillot mais la cinor
et nous nous battons pour qu'elle
augmente à lézat les abribus parce
qu'effectivement il manque des abribus
assainies vous avez raison et je vais le
rappeler votre appel pour dire que
notamment collège de montgaillard mais
dans d'autres endroits ceni il manque
des abribus il faut faire des abribus
parce que nous on est pour le bus pour
le le bus en site propre donc on veut
développer le bus et et il faut que les
gens soient un minimum de confort merci
monsieur est ce que gérald on vous
parlait justement sur saint denis ça va
être un peu compliqué votre adjoint il
est votre travail et vous le disiez il
va se présenter à la mairie de saintes
houari contre votre frère qui lui le
parti socialiste ont ouvert sans moi
j'ai pas gérer 5 paris des chalets chant
m'accuse occupé de cette femme et moi je
m'occupe de ça ni c'est un gros chantier
sani 150000 habitants
donc moi je suis concentré sur ça ni je
laisse ce qu'ils veulent à la question
de politique entre le parti socialiste
opposé le carbon non mais moi je n'ai
pas à arbitrer je suis ni responsable de
la république en marche ni responsable
du parti c'est une personnalité qui
compte suisse urs hany donc moi sur ce
nid au nom pour l'instant c'est sony qui
m'intéresse au point je me concentre et
je veux rassembler tous ceux qui veulent
porter le projet sur scénic
quand vous dites pour l'instant ça veut
dire que ça pourrait écouter aujourd'hui
il est trop tôt pour parler de ça moi
j'ai un chantier ccni cheveux le réussir
je veux que les dionysiens soient fiers
des dionysiens donc je me bats tous les
jours pour réussir ce n est rien nous
appelle des bourses et un break
enfin j'étais dans le football quand
vous étiez président de la ligue de
football
ses 40 ans répond oui bah c'est juste
que vous demandez qui pourrait pas
donner un petit coup de pouce voix
baptisé de la maison régionale des
sports avec de football donc non
monsieur de corte et sans tabous ya des
deux deux piliers de la ligue
oui city 10 secrétaires effectivement
qui ont dit bon je vais transmettre
votre suggestion à monsieur yves ethève
qui est le président donc si à lui il a
décidé avec son équipe mais m'a fait
aller un petit mot en faisant référence
à de corte effectivement qui était un
pilier de la liga je vais voir ce qu'il
en pense on va rentrer quand ella volcan
la coulée mais n'a jamais je n'aurais
déjà là et alors monsieur de cotes sont
taboues iata la rue de paradis à mahdia
sa yves ethève un mois mois passé un
coup de fil pour dire que nous propose
ok merci merci merci pour votre appel
dans le monde du foot non moi en tant
que maire je m'occupe du développement
du sport à saigner je me réjouis
globalement un pack du foot que c'est ni
par exemple à la fin de l'année on remet
rend célèbre entre guillemets en
récompense 180 athlètes assainies qui
font un podium national international
donc le sport a changé en quarante ans
et c'est à l'honneur de la réunion dans
toutes les disciplines et c'est le sport
va bien j'espère qu'on va bien se
comporter aux prochains jeux des îles 1
puisque c'est un enjeu régional mais il
ya un peu d'amour propre de fierté
réunionnaise
quand il faut croiser avec les malgaches
les seychellois les mauriciens on a
gagné les derniers jeux moi je souhaite
évidemment que nous gagnons les
prochains jeux à maurice dans quelques
mois on a parlé tout à l'heure un peu
d'aménagements avec les lézards et du
sourire content non plus
un peu lourde qui est celle de la
nouvelle route du littoral en parler sa
taille et une nouvelle réunion la région
avec le collectif contre la digue
d'abord qu'est-ce que vous pensez de
cette question là est-ce qu'il faut
continuer afin d'y goisque on peut
envisager une autre année ou de la
nouvelle entrée ouest
on a des bonnes nouvelles sur neo parce
que c'est un projet qui va prendre corps
cette année nous allons construire
falcon lui dis nous c'est davantage la
région puisque c'est un nous sommes en
avec la région mais c'est la région qui
est maîtresse ouvrage on nous avons ce
tronçon entre le rond point avec la rue
de la route de la montagne à côté de la
caserne jusqu'à la rue de paris avec
surtout la construction d'un nouveau
pont à quatre voies sur le live hier
sony et ce projet qui est de l'ordre de
50 millions va démarrer l'année
prochaine c'est le première étape de neo
on suit les prochaines qu'on a une idée
dans cette année au calendrier un peu
précis non je ne peux pas le dire mais
cette année les travaux démarrent cette
année les budgets sont là ils démarrent
dont pourquoi parce que cette première
tranche doit être en mesure d'absorber
l'arrivée de la nouvelle route du
littoral et de dispatcher en quelque
sorte le flux est de faire sauter ce
goulot d'étranglement qui est le pont
sur la rivière sony ensuite nous avons
des études qui sont courts qui avance
sur le tunnel enfin le tunnel louis sous
le souterrain pardon sous le ballon sous
le barachois plus un souterrain
également à la hauteur là vous voyez de
des archives de l andré auteur d'études
oui mais des études qui avance bien et
nous sommes en train bien sûr nous
préparons les négociations sur le
financement du c'est un projet à 400
millions mais l'état la région et la
mairie sont volontaires parties
prenantes et nous mènerons à bien ce
projet qui est essentiel si on fait pas
des eaux la route du littoral sera
embouteillée jusqu'à la possession elle
servira à rien donc tout le monde a
compris que la route
l'entrée ouest de nouvelle route entre
20 et capitale notamment pour le
développement du tourisme sur a fait
cent bouteilles âge aussi avec les
touristes qui débarquent à gillot
puisque on attend 3 millions de
passagers à gillot nous avons aliette au
téléphone bonjour à l'étranger
on jouera liette
du plateau bon j'ai deux questions oui
bon je vais dit que son mandat avait
atteint 80% c'est bien mais dommage on
va pas marcher cab attendait à toutes
les personnes pour l'environnement c'est
pas si misé à ces salles et on n'a pas
le reste et des travailleurs municipaux
et puis nous on est assassiné tous les
dimanches avec le maillot du chaudron
avec ses motos qui font de la guerre
tous les tous les dimanches avec la moto
donc c'est invivable 35 routier des
chaudrons oui merci bien c'est bien
madame alors sur l'environnement vous
savez impressions et vous ça vous l'avez
dit c'est un double problème c'est le
problème de ceux qui nettoient il faut
qu'ils soient plus efficaces nous allons
augmenter les moyens
nous avons un plan propreté mais vous
avez faits reprochés oui annoncé que des
associations nous allons subventionner
des associations qui vont embaucher
notamment leuglay mais d'autres
solutions mais ensuite nous avons le
problème de ceux qui salissent et là
vous savez que c'est un problème de
comportement de mentalités sont un
travail auprès des déjà nous allons
multiplier les opérations de
sensibilisation avec nettoyons de
quartier avec des associations
d'éducation populaire donc c'est un
travail de longue haleine mais nous
partageons votre réflexion comme quoi
sur l'environnement la propreté les
choses sont laisse à désirer qu'il faut
faire un effort sur les rodéos les motos
sur les rodéos madame moi je suis en
relation constante avec le directeur de
la police
et je vous le dis non pas pour m'excuser
mais c'est un prêt dont un phénomène
national régional mondial c'est la
rebellion des jeunes nous sommes en
train de travailler avec des
associations sur le chaudron pour
essayer de diminuer neutraliser mais la
police qui a la charge ce phénomène se
sentent parfois impuissante face à la
complexité de ce phénomène mais comme la
police nationale comme la police
américaine donc on est face à quelque
chose de dramatique et nous sommes en
train de chercher si vous avez quelques
idées il faut participer nous en
remettre un groupe de travail avec les
habitants notamment des calebasses y est
nous avons
quelques volontaires qui veulent aider à
repérer ceux qui sont les animateurs de
ce phénomène et nous allons travailler
aussi avec une piste spéciale à gillot
pour offrir quelque chose aux jeunes
bien mais moi j'ai su allier je suis
entièrement d'accord avec vous comme
j'ai dit bon mais c'est pas aux
policiers sont ils sont malheureux aussi
faire tous ces délinquants donc c'est
autorisé je vois que des personnes qui
filme des parents qui fument nord
la progéniture en train de faire le
rodéo charge cette route le but originel
je suis un bon gamin pop a pour dix ans
on vienne recruter je me le dire la
mairie 18 agents de surveillance de
l'espace public donne bien aura deux
jeux tout net il y en aura deux sur the
draw il ya neuf quartiers 2 par quartier
qui vont toute la journée là aujourd'hui
demain sillonné le chaudron pour
verbaliser le stationnement
l'environnement et le bruit donc c'est
une nouvelle organisation un effort 18
agents sont en cours de recrutement pour
essayer de pacifier l'espace public
c'est un peu un effort supplémentaire et
je suis d'accord avec vous on est un peu
démuni face à ceux ci rodéo merci merci
alex désolé a dit en arrivant enfin en
fin d'émission
merci à vous on suivra les débats 6e
fois effectivement dans le quartier même
avec les propositions merci à vous
d'avoir participé à vous monsieur le
maire
gibernau qui étaient avec nous dans l'un
des politiques on peut retrouver
l'émission en podcast sur le site de la
première merci à vous bassiner sur la
commune du tampon va vivre un événement
important
l'arrivée de l'eau de la source edgar
avril et rendez vous le dimanche 3 mars
à partir de 9h30 sur le belvédère de
bois court l'inauguration sera suivie
des compères d'alfredo fontaine et demie
stylo c'est sacré au tampon l'hôpital
gabriel martin de saint-paul des ménages
les 5 et 6 mars vers le centre
hospitalier ouest réunion le shore
pendant cette période nous vous invitons
à consulter votre médecin traitant en
première intention et bien sûr pour les
urgences fait le 15 afin d'être orientés
vers une structure adaptée
toutes nos activités de soins reprennent
dès le 7 mars au shore votre nouvel
hôpital de l'ouest à cambaie ecoutez-la
la première signa qui est installée pour
vous accompagner
icloud installé je me suis installé j'ai
éteint les lumières
oui je vois ça c'est ambiance tamisée
hélène alors alain barrière c'est après
midi elle manie comme ça j'ai tué ma
fille une réserve en petits morceaux de
mousse et quant aux dimensions une autre
vie comment ils chantent sont encore
maintenus oublier une autre
existe-t-il une autre barrière que je
connais bien parce que c'est un breton
oui il a une boîte de nuit fallait il
avait prescrit leur fils à sa fille
karbala du côté de carnac ce n'est pas
seulement boîte de nuit
merci pour cette belle mission g 6 à
demain
intel phonique à tout ça alors là des va
virer sa cuti vase est menaçable anisé
folie coat systems bones en cercle à
dire à ces quelques balles
on s'en fout il est venu guerre
ciao
las